moscow says that it is not targeting
civilians in ukraine but this morning
russian forces shot and killed 10 people
in the city of chernhiv as they stood
waiting in line for brett
we have independently verified this
video
we don't know what happened in the
moments leading up to the attack but
nothing has emerged to suggest that this
was anything other than murder in cold
blood
21 days now and this attritional war
grinds on
russian forces continue to shell
ukrainian cities with no regard for what
they hit
but western intelligence says that they
have barely advanced in the past 24
hours because the ukrainian resistance
is holding up
independent analysts have said that at
least 15 russian helicopters were
destroyed when ukrainian artillery hit
this base outside the town of kersen
these satellite images show the fires
still burning
president putin speaking today is still
insisting that his invasion is going
according to plan
in terms of the military tactics
developed by the russian ministry of
defence and the general staff they were
completely justified and our lads
soldiers and officers have shown bravery
and heroism
and they're doing everything they can to
avoid loss of civilian life in ukrainian
cities
putin seemed to acknowledge the effect
that sanctions have had on the country
but was nonetheless defined
that's just not
yes things are not easy for us now
russian financial campaigns large-scale
enterprises small and medium-sized
businesses face unprecedented pressure
our banking system was the first to get
hit by the sanctions but the russian
banks got over this challenge
nato defense ministers met in brussels
today and agreed to send more troops to
the eastern borders the massive support
the ukraine armed forces are receiving
and actually have received from nato
other countries over many years
have
forced president putin to change his
plans
diplomatic talks are said to be making
progress but there's no knowing when a
deal might be agreed if at all and what
ukraine would agree to give up in return
for peace
everywhere you look here there are
people displaced families broken apart
relatives dead
and lives wrecked tomorrow will mark
three weeks since the russian invasion
began
how much longer will they have to live
like this
alastair bunker sky news in western
ukraine